but first the question that seemingly
everybody in the world is desperate to
know the answer to
will donald trump run for president
again
in 2024
so here's the big question for you
which everybody wants to know the latest
poll says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat joe biden by six
points and kamala harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the united states so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything i'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this i think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
i love our country our country is going
to hell i think a lot of people are
going to be very happy you're going to
run i'm not gonna say that but i think
people are gonna be happy you might even
be happy if it's you against joe biden
if you win the republican nomination
again and he runs again
would you beat him
uh i believe right now anybody i think
you could beat him right now our
country's a mess our country has never
been so disrespected our borders have
never been so open we've never had in 44
years inflation like we have it you run
again
and you win
which could well happen i think whoever
the republican candidate
right now it looks like the democrats
are going to get shellacked in the
midterms it's quite likely whoever is a
republican nominee
will end up being president it could be
you again
and for as many people who think that's
a great idea you'll know there are lots
of people who think that would be a
total nightmare far less
far less i think so yeah i think far
less i think people are very angry at
this country they're very angry at our
leadership
they wish they had their vote to do
again
we didn't need their vote because again
we won the election by a tremendous
margin we won the election actually very
easily
one of the other questions about
potentially running again is you've been
in that pressure cauldron of the white
house with your family they've all come
under huge attack your children your
wife melania
would you be happy to put them back in
there would they be happy to be back in
there well i won't get into that but i
will tell you they all love the country
and we did a great job it's been a
tumultuous time for the world for the
country
there is a chance that you're going to
be running quite clearly you've made
that clear in this interview i don't
think i've made it clear some people are
going to i think that's it but i think
people are going to be very happy i
don't know there'll be people unhappy
but i think people are going to be very
happy so those who are
who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you i know you said recently that you
were very popular and i think he said
he'd be the most honest man in the world
i'm a very honest man was that true
yeah i think i'm a very honest man but
for those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah i'm
pretty honest because i don't think
you're real right yeah i think i'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am i not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead
go ahead go ahead next question was this
what message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had
of being president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently so i like this question
in a certain way because i came in and i
was attacked from day one
unfairly russia russia russia was a hoax
the impeachment hoax number one number
two it was all a big hoax the mueller
report
and i had to fight back and i had to
fight back strongly and if i didn't
fight back strongly i wouldn't have
survived and i say it and i say it loud
i had two jobs to do
run the country really well and the
second was to survive no other president
went through this fake stuff i only ask
you is when we did celebrity apprentice
together
which i've really enjoyed and it was
good yeah yeah yeah
when i did that with you i saw a very
different donald trump in the boardrooms
for those hours every night
you were you know you weren't as
aggressive and confrontational except i
wasn't under siege with phony with phony
russian russia
by the way
the russian collision thing was
ridiculous no no and many others right
but my point is if you got a chance
again
would we see more of that donald trump
do you think
depends on how you're greeted but if you
greet it unfairly you have to be tough
and you have to fight i would like that
i would much prefer that but it depends
on how you agreed it but
i would do
when i say this our country's in trouble
something has to happen and if it
doesn't happen and if we don't have
smart leadership you're going to end up
with no world the world is going to be
blown to pieces we have stupid people
now running our country the world is
going to be blown to pieces